all right the time has come we are
covering the Bernie Sanders live Fox
News Town Hall this evening or afternoon
because it's only 3:30 p.m. on the west
coast which is exactly when I would
imagine Fox News with scheduled a Bernie
Sanders Town Hall when people are either
getting ready to wrap up work commuting
home in that horrible LA traffic or
whatever else so we'll talk about that
we as far as I know the Town Hall starts
in about 14 minutes I am monitoring what
is happening over on Fox News right now
it's commercials so as soon as things
get going I will bring it all to you
don't worry about that I may take phone
calls after neath after the Town Hall
depending on whether we get 10 new
members as it says down there but I will
take questions and super chats up until
the Town Hall starts quick sort of
thoughts from me about this Town Hall
there are good arguments to be made on
both sides of Bernie doing this and not
doing this of course going right into
the den of the propaganda arm of the
Trump administration Fox News Fox News
host Sean Hannity regularly speaks to
trump on the phone puts him to bed late
at night metaphorically not literally as
far as we know and it is very likely
that what Fox News did to me when I went
on they will do to Bernie Sanders but
way worse
this could include I'm not saying these
things will happen I'm telling you what
can be done lighting that won't make
Bernie look good planted questions from
people that are sort of skilled in being
adversarial in these situations
tag-teaming Bernie as a moderation team
I believe there are two moderators in a
way that moderators typically would not
do so there are all sorts of things that
Fox News could do to make Bernie look
bad I don't know that they're going to
do them and there's sort of two primary
arguments that that are the most
important ones for me and thinking about
whether this does or doesn't make sense
to Bernie Sanders if you're against
Bernie Sanders doing this the argument
would be you're legitimizing the
propaganda a reality that is Fox
you are legitimizing them in a way that
they don't deserve to be legitimized and
thus Bernie should just stay away in the
end very few people who are actually
voting for Bernie in the primary are
going to exclusively learn about Bernie
by watching Fox News sure there are
leftists that watch fox news often
friends retainment value but they would
hear about Bernie anyway so that would
be an argument for Bernie not doing it
the strongest argument for Bernie doing
it is if not so much for the Democratic
primary but for his national name
recognition and potentially for his
national election against Donald Trump
in 2020 why not get in front of the Fox
News audience and see if there are
people who are willing to hear reason
and to sort of consider your perspective
because you're not going to hurt
yourself by appearing on Fox News given
your political positions if you're
Bernie Sanders maybe there is something
to be gained if you appear on Fox News I
would respect the decision either way
I've personally when I've been invited
on Fox I've done it knowing that the
tables will be sort of tilted against me
and just try to make the best of it and
and the idea that if I can break
someone's echo-chamber that's worthwhile
and I think that that's likely something
that Bernie Sanders would be able to do
at the same time if he said this is not
my audience and decided not to do it
that would be completely fine as well
Bernie is doing it so we are going to
cover it and we are going to talk about
it so we are currently waiting for this
thing to get going i thought that bret
baier was one of the moderators it's
interesting that he's doing the news
right now but I guess eventually he'll
walk over to wherever the debate the
Town Hall is going to be happening Fox
News also letting us know that Bernie
Sanders has in advance of this Fox News
townhall fulfilled his prep pledge to
release ten years of tax returns I've
already dealt with the entire Bernie's a
millionaire issue yeah so what a lot of
people who are Bernie's age have a
million dollars in net worth including
real estate and it's really just not a
big deal
it doesn't make him exorbitant ly rich
period and that's that's that's
basically it so we will be of course
talking about that more let me see if I
can make a small adjustment here through
the shot I think we're in pretty good
shape let's make sure we have audio so
that when this thing starts we'll
actually be able to hear it tax return
we do right back to you and just quickly
Susan he did take the deductions yeah oh
my goodness Bernie Sanders took
deductions okay we'll get back to that
later but in any case we are waiting for
the Bernie Sanders Town Hall if this is
your first live stream that you've seen
these are actually live unless you are
watching an archive which means you can
participate you can use the super chat
function at the bottom of the chat
window that is the dollar sign that'll
pop up your questions or comments on the
screen and then I will answer questions
or respond to comments please sign up
for membership okay tomorrow I'm going
to outline just the absolute insanity
that is going on with YouTube right now
but in any case we are sort of in fund
raising mode outside of YouTube and one
of the best things you can do including
if you want me to open up the phone
lines after the Town Hall is just to
become a member on our website to coupon
codes are listed in the video
description if you include your area
code in either the first or last name
fields in addition to your name when you
sign up I will get to you first if and
when we open up the phone lines after
the Town Hall so that is going on ten
members and I will open up the phone
lines I was just actually in in Las
Vegas and one of the people I was
talking to was Sam cedar and we used the
same phone system and we were both
talking about how the phone bills are
getting completely out of control from
regularly having 30 40 or 50 people
holding often for an hour and it is a
phone system that works extraordinarily
well we can conference 10 viewers
together imagine if we did that it does
a lot of really great things but we do
pay for it so that's why we usually tie
opening the phone lines on live streams
to new memberships and I will sing your
praises
if you sign up and the phone lines will
get opened and you'll be able to talk to
me and it'll just all be absolutely
tremendous so that is something to look
forward to after the livestream I do
have one super chat that came in which I
will address right now David are sent a
five-dollar super chat asking David do
you feel as I do that andrew Yang's
proposal to decriminalize heroin and
other hard drugs is going to turn a lot
of people off well remember
decriminalize and legalize are two
different things and I've said that of
course I've been for the legalization of
marijuana for who knows how long and of
course we need to be decriminalizing
drugs and dealing with drugs as a public
health issue but I am just unsure right
now about the legalization of heroin I'm
not ideologically or morally or
ethically against it I just have not
read enough about what the impact would
be decriminalization seems to make a lot
of sense to me so I'm not concerned
about that yes any position any elected
official or potential elected official
takes could turn them off but I am not
hugely worried about that let me see
I've got a little bit of not enough
Headroom here let me see if I can make a
small adjustment to my shot just to
better let's see I think that that's
much better okay P primal I guess sends
a twenty seven dollar super chat with a
link to law enforcement action
partnership org which with peace and
love I'm not going to click on right now
because who knows what that would pop up
on the screen but law enforcement action
partnership org is the website that
primal is promoting and I really
appreciate the $27 super chap something
people can visit if they so want so
we're standing by here it looks like we
are just a few minutes from Bernie
Sanders they've actually put there's a
clock in the bottom right which my video
is covering up let's see if I can move
that around here there it is Bernie
Sanders Town Hall six minutes and twenty
seconds away and we have Brit Hume
talking to us just isn't
let's listen to what Brits talking about
started claiming that nobody really got
much of a tax cut it all went to the 1%
and so on as you've heard people like
Bernie Sanders say and many others that
isn't quite true but and and you have to
wonder why we're there now playing the
game that that the tax cuts for the rich
are for Bernie Sanders which is I better
hand it to him that's pretty freakin
clever as far as propaganda goes that is
pretty damn clever because even though
the 1% versus the 0.5% vs. the point 1
percent are just can't Grand Canyon's
apart now I'm guessing on the basis of
the Bernie Sanders tax returns that have
been released Bernie has a million
dollar net worth now they're saying it's
not just tax cuts for rich people like
Bernie which is of course
extraordinarily insincere but but sort
of brilliant from Fox News so we'll get
we'll get back to this I think I can
move my video back down so I will not be
in the way when this thing actually gets
gets going we are standing by for Bernie
Sanders on Fox News Town Hall we will
the there's the expectation that this is
going to last about an hour and I am
willing to go directly to the phone
lines when the Town Hall is over if we
have 10 people who sign up for
membership and I can prepare the phone
lines while we are still watching the
Town Hall which will all be very very
exciting let's see what other super
chats we have the progressive voices
what did you and Sam cedar do at the
night club at the night club I don't
even know what that means but we didn't
uh we didn't do much of anything we just
talked to people during the social
events that took place in Las Vegas
David R says David understanding this
live stream is about the Bern can you
share some quick thoughts on Andrew
Yang's performance last night on a CNN
Town Hall I think Andrew yang performed
extremely well but said a lot of things
I disagree with like for example when he
said Medicare for all buy-in that's not
me that's not my position Medicare for
all buy-in that's not what I'm pushing
for when he said he is against unions I
would love to also be against unions in
the sense that I wish they weren't
necessary based on the relationship and
power dynamics between big corporations
and employers and individual workers but
we need unions right now and very very
few workers are actually represented by
them so as far as his performance I
think andrew yang did well was he sort
of playing to the right in some way I
don't think so I mean I can't say that
for sure for certain one way or the
other but he said more things that on a
policy sort of perspective I just don't
agree with and maybe we'll get an
opportunity to talk about those with
Andrew yang once again xavier h sends a
dollar superjet the progressive voice
sends a dollar ninety-nine superjet
andrew yang is a clown dude interesting
analysis not really much I can respond
with because it is not particularly
substantive soft ransom when is patent
gonna take off his shirt something you'd
have to ask pat about something that you
would have to ask pat about for sure
okay we are getting very very close to
Bernie Sanders Fox News Town Hall um
there are currently ads playing on Fox
News so I'm not going to switch over
quite yet because I why why do that
right that doesn't really make any sense
if people want to call in after the Town
Hall ends I am glad to take phone calls
the way to get the phone lines opened is
by signing up at www.sceeto.com on code
SAVE 35 to drop a $60 membership to just
25 bucks and if just 10 of you sign up
we will go right to the phones after the
live stream a couple of other super
chats the needle drop Anthony Fantino
stopping by for the David Pakman legal
fund I believe you'll prevail against
Sam in court Dave good luck yes of
course
major litigation taking place in the set
fiasco
with Sam cedar a friend of mine called
me yesterday and said man I can't
believe this lawsuit stuff with Sam
cedar and I said to him it's just a joke
it's it really is a joke it's not real
we're just kidding around
Jordan Oliver with a ten dollar super
Chad I fall center-right and turn to
your channel to keep me out of an echo
chamber
I do feel your channel has shifted to
focus more on the presentation from the
right instead of content no focus more
on the presentation from the right
instead of content I don't think so I
don't fully understand what you're
saying but I don't think so and Alfonzo
Saldana says move to amend.org and end
corporate personhood rights and
established once and for all that money
is not a form of speech check out bill
HR j48 agree and bonito Pitino says do
you think Bernie will benefit from this
Town Hall I believe that it is all
upside I think there is a very very
little downside to Bernie Sanders doing
this Town Hall I think there are very
good reasons for why he wouldn't do it
and I would have respected him if that
was his decision but I think it makes
sense to try to reach people anybody you
might be able to convince is worthwhile
at this scale I don't recommend trying
to convince Trunk voters on a one-on-one
level in your personal life not to vote
for Trump you're way better off just
getting out the vote from people who are
already on the left but I think that
there is potentially a lot to be gained
Tripp Samuel says thoughts on the 2016
Assange interview mention of Seth rich
was he being intentionally misleading
I barely remember that so I'd have to
review it Tripp I know that that took
place but I don't remember the specifics
of what was said so I will have to go
back and review that okay so we're
standing by and I think we're about to
get going so let's start digging in here
to what's happening on the Democratic
nomination
[Applause]
senator Bernie Sanders says he's going
all the way what's gonna be different
this time we're gonna win okay so while
this introduction starts the idea will
be I believe there are going to be
breaks during the town hall I will read
super chats during the town hall and
welcome new members so keep them all
coming and then if we get 10 new members
during this Town Hall right at 7:30 p.m.
Eastern we will go to the phone lines so
that's the that's the game plan let's
see what's going on Keith Jobs and his
vision for the future of America
[Music]
scream drop
[Applause]
now shuddered at Bethlehem Steel Plant
it's a Bethlehem Steel plant plant blast
those furnaces and the produced
thousands of tons of steel a day that
steel built skyscrapers and helped the
u.s. win two world wars the plant closed
in 1995 really devastating this
working-class community but now there is
a new day dawning in Bethlehem
economically and politically here in
North Hampton country which Northampton
County which is where we are they voted
for President Barack Obama in big
numbers okay Democrat all the way back
to Bush 40 let me explain here what
they're doing this is an attack on
Democrats this is just saying we're in a
place that is not doing well because of
Democrats that did that it's already in
extraordinarily biases hoping to get
those voters back in the blue column
according to all recent polls he's
leading among declared Democrat
candidates ladies and gentlemen seven
guys and of course Democrat candidates
just say Democratic candidates start
we're gonna get a lot of questions from
the audience Martha and I will follow up
throughout let's start by getting right
to our audience our first question is
from Joe he is a student from Allentown
PA Joe what's your question hey Joe hi
senator Sanders now that you're touched
released and you have been identified as
a millionaire and in the top 1% will you
pay your fair share and how do you plan
to apply the policies that you have been
talking about and forcing on top earners
that's a ridiculous well you pay your
fair share I happen to believe Joe that
we have an absurd tax system and while
millions of people today are paying
actually more in taxes than they
anticipated amazon netflix and dozens of
major corporations as a result of
Trump's tax bill paid nothing in federal
taxes I think that's a disgrace so today
we announced
now you raise the issue I am a
millionaire well actually this year we
had five hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in income that's a lot of money
and that money in my case my wife's case
it came from a book that I wrote pretty
good book you might want to read it it's
a best-seller sold all over the world
and we made money so if anyone thinks
that I should apologize for writing a
best-selling book I'm sorry I'm not
going to do it good so far but let me
reiterate I voted a gut so I guess on
Fox News you said that I benefited from
Trump's tax bill did you tell people
that I voted against Trump's tax bill
sure but you did this is uh this is
redic I mean listen I've talked about I
benefited from it as well the question
is what's the economic utility of the
tax by Trump who told the American
people that that tax bill some of you
may recall would not benefit the wealthy
you remember that oh not gonna bet to
benefit the wealthy 83% of the benefits
went to the top one percent so I think
that's a bad idea
and in my view people whether it's me
you probably make a lot more money than
I do but whether it's big or you really
else I think
wealthy people and large corporations
that are making billions of profits
should start paying their fair share of
taxes
to to your points and to Joe's point
your taxes do show that you're a
millionaire you did make a million
2016-2017 you're right that 561 and 2018
but your marginal tax rate was 26
percent because of President Trump's tax
cut so why not say you know I'm leading
this revolution I'm not gonna take those
ridiculous hearing the I am I paid the
taxes that I go and by the way once you
got Donald Trump up here and asked him
how much he pays in taxes president I
guess the president watches your network
a little bit right hey president Trump
my wife that I just released 10 years
please do the same let the American you
know he's getting it the right thing but
he's sort of his misstating you just say
me paying anything is not a policy we
need policy around taxi phenomenally
well right now as you know for 40 years
we have seen a shrinking middle class we
got 40 million people living in poverty
and today just so happens that the very
wealthy are doing incredibly wealthy
it's not vilifying to say that people
have a whole lot of money in some cases
billions of dollars of wealth they
should pay their fair share of taxes
right well a lot about vilify my last
question on this a lot of millionaires
and billionaires give a ton to charity
you gave three point four percent my
wife and I do give money to charity all
right and we're proud to do what we did
or all does you're quite right they were
up people Gates Foundation do a
phenomenal job we do what we do I got a
couple questions for you so you you
recommended a wealth tax 70% wealth tax
no actually I didn't that was 70 percent
no I think another person what's your
number
what's my number well I'll tell you what
I think I think that in order to make
sure that elderly people do not continue
to live in poverty and you got twenty
percent of elderly
we're trying to get by them thirteen or
fourteen thousand dollars a year I think
we should raise that cap for people
making two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars or more so we can make sure that
our parents can live out their lives of
dignity I'll tell you what else I think
I think at a time when Wall Street is
doing phenomenally well and we have
millions of young people who are deeply
in debt for the crime of having gone to
college I believe we should pass a
speculation tax I'm asking you about the
wealthy and how much higher you would
make it
you said you don't agree with 70% what
would your number be in the campaign in
2016 we talked about 52%
all right so 52% so would you be willing
to pay fifty two percent on the money
that you made you can volunteer you can
send it could volunteer to wait that's
not how marginal tax rates work I mean
this is the height of idiocy wealth tax
is on wealth she's talking about a
marginal tax rate which would only be on
the income above a certain I mean this
is just idiots fight for a wealth tax
and we're going to demand that we end
the absurdity where major corporation
after major companies build that you are
defending families like the culprits
like the Koch brothers get billions and
billions of dollars in savings
daddy is absurd Trump wants to repeal
the entire estate tax huge tax breaks
for billionaires you got another
question well we have many questions and
listen we want to get substance we want
to get details do it and the audience
has a ton of questions - all right
Martha so our question comes from Kathy
Harrington Kathy what's your question
senator hi senator Sanders welcome to
the Lehigh Valley so my question is the
definition of socialism is just a
society agreeing to work together and
combining their resources to make sure
everyone is protected and taken care of
how can you challenge the idea that
socialism is bad and then the minds of
the public
mother asked them not me what is this
what to be a constant thing alright
alright
you asked me fair questions I will give
you a fairy thank you sir yeah you know
everybody for thought I should come on
this show and we appreciate it all right
your network does not necessarily have a
great deal of respect in my world but I
thought it was important for me to be
here and have a serious discussion about
serious issues Sally asked a good
question
thanks for that question Sally
and let's let's look about it I think
it's an important issue but it will come
up
what is the democratic socialism fair
question yeah let's talk about it
democratic socialism to me is creating a
government and an economy and a society
which works for all rather than just the
top 1% it means ending the absurd
inequalities that exists today and I
want to lay this out because you're not
gonna hear this much on Fox and you're
not gonna hear this much in the media in
general and the American people have got
to conclude whether we think it is
appropriate and what America is about
have three families owning more wealth
than the bottom half of the American
Society 160 million people whether it's
appropriate for the top 1% to own more
wealth than the bottom ninety two
percent whether it is right that 49
percent of all the we've come goes to
the top one percent when many people
brett maloha watching this program are
working two or three jobs just to pay
the bills so first of all we want to
create a government that works for all
of us and we want to create a political
system it which is based on one-person
one-vote not billionaires buying
elections as a result of this disastrous
Citizens United
please stay for democracy and rival
further when I talk and they you know
people have different views of
capitalism with democratic socialism
whatever it may be but this is my view I
believe that human beings especially in
a wealthy democratic civilized society
like our own are entitled to certain
basic rights so let me be very clear and
I'm sure we'll discuss it later in the
show bread I believe that health care is
a human right
and I believe I believe that there is
something embarrassingly wrong when the
United States of America is the only
major country on earth not the
guaranteeing health care to all people I
live three miles from the Canadian
border so health care is right I believe
that education whether you're poor
whether you're rich you have the right
to get all of the education you need and
that is why I believe we should make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free we're going to talk about
all of this and we're gonna try to talk
about how you pay for it which is a real
quality but I just want to back on the
the taxes briefly you know when you
wrote wrote the book and you made the
money yeah isn't that the definition of
capitalism are you married right now no
I mean you know what we want is a
country where everybody has opportunity
you know I have a college degree
like I'm a United States Senator but a
lot of people don't have a college
degree a lot of people on top United
States senators I want everybody in this
country to be able to have health care
to have education to when they turn on
the water have drinkable water not toxic
water so what we are fighting for Brett
is a society not we're just a few people
can make a whole lot of money but if
society where everybody in this country
has the opportunity to live in security
and dignity all right out there this
weekend people to judge the mayor of
South Bend announced that he is also
candidate for the Democratic nomination
he's running and here's what he said in
South Bend movin like that calls for
hopeful and audacious voices from
communities like ours and yes it calls
for a new generation of leadership in
this country
so Buddha judge obviously is the
youngest candidate he would certainly be
the youngest president if he were to win
that's 37 years old and you are 77 years
old sir he's calling for a new
generation he didn't name anyone
specifically but what do you say to
those who have raised the question of
whether or not you are would be too old
at 79 as president well following me
around the campaign trail I mean it is a
fair question it's a fair question and
all I can say is there was wood here
light knock on it thank God my health is
good I was when I was a kid I was a
long-distance runner one of the better
my lives in New York City and I
continued to have my endurance but I
think when you look at a candidate yeah
you could look at age that's fair you
could look at experience I was a mayor
for eight years and a little bit about
local government I was a member of the
House I'm a member of the United States
Senate I've been all over the world
talking to heads of state so I mean I
think it is a combination of factors but
at the end of the day this is what I
honestly believe it's not what the young
it's not whether you're old it is what
you believe it and I have to say and I
have to say this is this is not a
criticism of Fox this is a criticism of
media in general there is too much focus
on individuals and not enough focus on
the American people and what their needs
are and I want to tell you this box this
is all the rest I go out and I listen to
the people they say give me they ask me
questions
those questions are often very very
different than the issues being
discussed by media on Capitol though
okay so all right senator we want to get
back to audience questions I do want to
say that we understand and we're very
grateful that you're here we are giving
you an hour of substance and talk on our
airwaves so we can get over the Fox
thing if you are I with that
okay Brian is it carries about here in
Brian what's your question
go ahead Brian hold on one second
Brian's got the floor senator Sanders as
a boy okay and as a member of both from
City Council welcome to the Christmas
City my question is as a lifetime
Kennedy Democrat more specifically
center-left my concern is that president
Trump has so enflamed are the Democratic
base that we will shift to far left and
overreach like the Republicans did with
the Tea Party in 2010 what are your
thoughts on that give me a break and
look this is what I say every day I
disagree with Donald Trump on virtually
every issue and I talk about it and I'll
tell you what upsets me but I'll tell
you what upsets me the most I'm gonna
answer your question is that whether
you're conservative or moderate or
progressive I don't think the American
people are proud that we have a
president who was a pathological liar
[Music]
you know it does not give me pleasure to
say that all right I disagreed with
george w bush on almost everything which
was not a pathological life Trump cannot
even tell the truth even as to where his
father was born but it really got crazy
his father was one in New York he claims
he was born in Germany but if you can't
even tell the truth about where your
father was one it's hard to believe
anything that he says but to answer your
question look if we spend all of our
time attacking Trump you know what
Democrats are gonna lose all right our
job our job is to lay out a vision that
makes sense to the working families of
this country and that's kind of what I'm
trying to do over a four-year period and
the video that you showed earlier I
think captured that we raised issues
four years ago which were thought to be
extreme and a little bit out there but
today they're accepted by the American
people so I think you talk to the people
of Bethlehem and Burlington Vermont you
say what song in what we're gonna want
among other things if you work 40 hours
a week people don't want to live in
poverty we got a raise
that minimum wage for living in my state
of Vermont and all over this country
we've got an infrastructure that is
falling about roads and bridges and
water systems wastewater but we can put
15 million people back to work with the
Chilean dollar investment I think that
makes sense to people so I agree with
you all right I mean I think Trump is a
dangerous president but if all we do is
focus on him we lose our job is to
develop an agenda that speaks to the
needs of workers when we do that we're
going to win and win big looks like Vice
President Joe Biden is likely to get
into the race are you worried that the
DNC if that you know he would be a
strong establishment candidate he's
obviously been around for a long time
are you worried that the DNC might put
his finger on the scale again the way
that they did to you back in 2016 with
Hillary claimant to that in 2016 and I
think we have come a long way since then
so we are we speak to the DNC every week
and I think the process will be fair one
of the important changes that we made
and we won is as you will recall both of
you recall being in the last time around
the 2016 Secretary Clinton had 500
super-delegates lined up behind her
before the first vote was cast in Iowa
and that seemed to be pretty dumb and
unfair well that process has been
changed and I think that works well for
everybody in the next round the
super-delegates will come into play and
with so many candidates on the
Democratic side it's possible that
somebody doesn't get 50% are you
concerned about it are you talking to
the DNC about that well that's what the
rule is I mean that's where we are right
now but you're right I mean I would hope
that the Democratic Party understands
what they did some years ago and that is
what we want to hear from is not
political insiders and campaign
contributors you want to hear from
ordinary people and I were in pencil
and they should determine who the next
Democratic nominee will be okay let's go
to another question Jordan is a student
from Scotch Plains here's the next
question
hi sittin there thank you so much for
being here my question is why do you
believe that the government can provide
better health care than the private
sector and why should people who like
their plans be forced to switch okay
first of all let's be clear what we mean
by Medicare for all okay Medicare is a
government-run program for seniors which
is widely popular and quite effective in
1965 when Lyndon Johnson passed that
bill it was called by some Republicans
socialism and everything else but you go
to the average senior and you say how do
you feel about Medicare and they will
tell you that they will oppose any
Republican effort to cut Medicare by the
way in Trump's budget he has proposed an
eight hundred and forty five billion
dollar cut over a 10-year period America
would seniors don't want so to answer
your question we are not talking about
government-run health care the Veterans
Administration and most veterans think
that that's a pretty good health care
system talk to the American Legion of
the VFW they strongly defend the
veterans healthcare that's
government-run what we are talking about
is simply a single-payer insurance
program which means that you will have a
card which says Medicare on it you'll go
to any doctor that you want you'll go to
any hospital that you want and by the
way millions of people today are in
networks which prevent them from doing
this so this gives you freedom of choice
with regard to the doctors you go to all
the hospitals you go but here is the
main point when we talk about healthcare
currently right now we've got 30 million
people zero health insurance and many of
you and tens of millions of Americans
are underinsured with high deductibles
and co-payments is that correct all
right so what happens is there are
estimates that some thirty thousand
Americans die every single
yeah because they don't go to the doctor
when they should alright
meanwhile we pay the highest prices in
the world for prescription drugs one out
of five Americans are getting ripped off
by the drug companies who make billions
in profits while charging us the highest
prices in the world and on top of all of
that we spend twice as much per capita
on health care as through the people of
any other nation so the question that I
throw back to you do you think it makes
sense to spend twice as much per capita
as the people of any other nation and be
the only country on where in the world
not to guarantee health care set all
people this audience this audience has a
lot of Democrats in it it has
Republicans independents Democratic
socialists conservatives I want to ask
the audience a question if you could
raise your hand here a show of hands of
how many people get their insurance from
work private insurance right now how
many get it from private insurance okay
now of those how many are willing to
transition to what the senator says a
government-run system it's not a
government-run system is a million
people on private they wouldn't be lost
right well to your question Oh Kirsten
good thanks what the right wing throws
out so let me ask all right millions of
people every single year lose their
health insurance you know why they get
fired or they quit and they go to
another employer I was a mayor for eight
years and what I did what probably every
mayor in America does is you look around
for the best insurance program most cost
effective ensure you change insurance
every year millions of workers wake up
in the morning and their employer has
changed the insurance that they have
maybe they like the doctor is up people
are nodding their heads okay so this is
not new every year now what we're
talking about actually is stability that
when you have a Medicare parole it is
there now
[Applause]
2014 the Democratic governor abandoned
it because he had to raise income taxes
had to raise in payroll taxes and the
people of Vermont didn't want their
taxes to go all courts and not in it
then they abandon so we're getting
internal Vermont politics of which I
know a little bit I'm saying I don't
want to be here the governor did a
rather poor job but I think if you look
at polling especially among Democrats as
I'm sure you have you tell me strong
majority of Democrats and more than a
few Republicans want to see a
medicare-for-all program what the
opponent so let's be clear about this
month when you are dealing with health
care which is was at 18% of our GDP I
mean we're talking about three and a
half trillion dollars again and you have
insurance companies that make billions
and billions of dollars in profit let me
give you an example if I might of the
dysfunctionality of the current health
care system recently Aetna merged with
CBS you may recall that big merger which
my view will drive health care costs up
the gentleman who was head of Aetna's
named mr. Bertolini you know what he got
for putting together that merger he got
a 500 million dollar bonus do you think
that's how we should spend help I think
everybody is an agreement that
healthcare needs to be fixed in this
country the question is how and my
question to you was if it will drive up
taxes to pay for health care and not
just the wealthy will pay for the middle
class will also pay for let's see how do
you justify it and Martha what are you
not including in your discussion right I
will tell you you're not gonna pay any
health insurance premiums
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look Healthcare is not free you know bro
suggests that we're gonna March you just
said it was gonna be free for everyone
it's gonna be free at the point of when
you use it okay
and you go to why are you so shocked by
this because she's a she'll be okay
we'll get through this together Ernie
will be accused of mansplaining by the
way you are self-employed and you have
got a husband and two kids okay family
of four do you know how much that family
is paying today for health care how
$28,000 see okay all right we're
spending $11,000 per person we are
saying to that family of four you ain't
gonna pay that 28,000 you're not paying
any more premiums you're not paying any
more co-payments you're not paying any
more deductibles how's that 28,000
you're not paying what does that mean
you're not gonna pay something of course
it does you're gonna pay more in taxes
and do members of Congress you now have
gold-plated health insurer we don't well
they have a special plan that's outside
Obamacare a different plan you remember
members of Congress are they going to do
that transition is that right why not
[Applause]
look health care cost money every other
country or virtually every country does
it in the same way we do education for
our kids okay when a kid walks into
school kid doesn't have to take out a
credit card right it's paid for out of
public funds that's what most countries
do so if you're asking me if your
question is a fair question or people
got to pay more in taxes yes but at the
end of the day the overwhelming majority
of people are going to end up paying
less for health care because in our pain
free
whole payments and deductibles we're
going to get into many more specifics
senator thank you coming up more of your
questions for senator bernie sanders
plus two of the issues that could end up
defining this is uh okay so we've got a
little bit of a break here this is
stunning what we are seeing III knew
that they were going to set this up to
try to create an environment that is
favorable to their right-wing audience
it wasn't so much about attacking Bernie
but of creating that environment they
don't even understand their own talking
points I mean Martha McCallum and Bret
Baier their heads are spinning and Bry
I've not seen anything like this and
I've watched a lot of this nonsense in
my day unbelievable truly truly
unbelievable we will get back to this
momentarily there are a few super chats
I will mention I'll put them on screen
just briefly here a a couple people who
have been making comments and I want to
get to to some of these but we will sort
of keep it here on the commercials that
Fox is airing be pissed
asked what's the next Bernie smear going
to be yeah well it's it's going to be
that he's rich we're already think
seeing that Ginelli nos said thoughts on
Trump and many others smearing and
putting a target on Elan Omar basically
putting her life in danger disgusting
covered it on the broadcast show today
Harry pothead says that the progressive
new media host should do a Sunday
roundtable show I would be up for doing
something like that junkyard joe says
stuff like can she fall out and other
post apocalyptic stuff has gotten
popular in the last few years does it
have anything to do with social anxiety
and escapism I think it does and j-dog
mix whistle sent a two dollar super chat
where he said one thousand dollars which
is very very exciting we have a lot of
people watching the Bernie townhall with
us today if you want to call in and talk
to me and I see a lot of people who are
angry with me I'm a smug know-it-all and
I'm queer and all of this different
stuff you can say it to my face I'll
open up the phone lines after we're done
it six one seven eight three zero forty
750 it would be my pleasure to take your
call and believe me I will do it and I
do it every week but we are targeting 10
new members at david pakman.com slash
membership it's really cheap it supports
the work that we do and it supports
these live streams
ww join pakman.com six bucks a month
sixty for the year use the coupon code
this is 20 22 save 40% if we get 10 new
members we will open up the phone lines
right after the Town Hall is over and it
will be a great time for all and by the
way if you are very angry with me
because I'm seeing comments I'm a
snowflake and all of this different
stuff if you want to debate me like
people are saying sign up put your area
code in either the first or last name
field so that I know when you call in
that it's you and I'll pick up on you
first and then you can give me a piece
of whatever it is you say that that
you're going to give me I see a lot of a
lot of Big Time talkers in the chat but
call in and tell me then let's let's
make it happen so you can sign up at WWE
supports the work that we do supports
the live streams we're talking about $2
in 8 cents a month if you use the coupon
code save 35 which you can use on a $60
membership $60 membership becomes 25
bucks if you use the coupon code save 35
let me know your area code when you sign
up and then I will pick up your call at
the bottom of the hour when this is over
and by the way let me see if I have I'll
play for you a sample voicemail from the
folks types of folks that like to call
in a very very angry folks who want to
talk to me here's one example here's the
Trump it's called Jimmy from Philly who
calls in okay there's a voicemail you
left me very recently David regarding
the abortion video you just dropped do
you mind if I ask a follow-up question
Jesus Christ how much soy could this
caller have absorbed but there you go
yeah so good you wanted to talk about so
sorry
boys or whatever call call in I welcome
your call and six months I see people
are calling in like crazy right now the
number would be six one seven eight
three zero 47 50 when we open the phone
lines but we will do that after the Town
Hall if ten people sign up at join
pakman.com let's get back to the Town
Hall here which is a total gang show so
far no there's there are opportunities
around it's actually been pretty good
job boys how's the economy and the job
picture around here this part of
Pennsylvania oh my god Steve do I think
boom or no that'll be honest do see I
usually do and we're doing really well
none of the locals we spoke to we're
concerned that the economy is struggling
here the overall feeling about jobs was
good which is something that could
complicate the eventual Democratic
nominees effort to flip Pennsylvania
right next year totally fair more
stand-up thank you Peter
welcome back everybody to the ArtsQuest
Center that you just saw in Peters great
story there the stone stacks in
Bethlehem Pennsylvania we're back with
our Town Hall the senator Bernie Sanders
let's take some more questions from our
audience hi Rodney what's your question
for senator Sanders thank you my
question for a sander sanders here's how
would you bring back jobs in industry of
like Bethlehem Steel that have been lost
due to in part trade deals that don't
favor the American working class hey
Rodney that's a great question
red-meat you are looking at a former
congressman and a senator who voted not
only voted against NAFTA walk the picket
lines with union workers to see that
voted against NAFTA voted against
permanent normal trade relations with
China strongly opposed the trans-pacific
partnership and why did I oppose all of
these disastrous trade agreements it was
very clear to me that these agreements
on the Democratic and Republican
leadership was written by multinational
corporations to make these corporations
even wealthier at the expense of the
American worker so let me suggest what
is not a radical idea American workers
should not have to compete against
desperate people around the world when
making a dollar or $2 an hour now I
think I think we have a moral
responsibility to lift up poor people
around the world along with the rest of
the wealthy countries but you can do
that without engaging in a race to the
bottom I know what I have heard you know
I have heard from you know I'm got a
100% lifetime pro-union voting we're
kind of very close to unions and I
talked to union workers and they say our
boss has said and if you don't take a
pay cut you don't take a cut in health
care we're gonna move to Mexico we're
gonna move to China where people are
prepared to work for almost nothing so
we need a trade is a good thing but we
need a trade policy that works for
working families and not just for the
large corporations package they're
people saying that they think the
economy is doing pretty well here so in
in Pennsylvania you've got unemployment
is down the past couple of years wages
are up six point six percent so how do
you convince those people in this area
who I know you'd like to win over this
time around that they should you know
sort of change horses and
with you what if things are going well
yeah well let's that's a fair question
and let's look what's going on not only
in the United States around the world I
know Donald Trump will tell you that he
is responsible for the relatively low
unemployment which we currently
experience well guess what in 2010
at the heart of the Wall Street Crash
unemployment in America was 10% remember
by the time Obama left office it was
4.5% so gone down and in the last
two-and-a-half years under Trump it has
gone down again where we at three and a
half percent now that's good okay but
there's been a steady decline do you
know what unemployment is in Germany now
3.1 percent in Japan it's 2.8 percent in
the UK it's a hair higher than us in
other words the entire global economy
thank God is bouncing back for the
terrible terrible wall street disaster
that costs so many jobs and caused so
much suffering in this country okay
youth today that has nothing to do with
the Trump it does certainly not what I'm
suggesting to you is the facts are very
clear is that in Japan in Germany United
Kingdom all over the world thank god
it's a good thing the global economy is
coming back and unemployment is
relatively low now I know Trump will
give a slightly different spin on it but
in the midst of all of this in the
current economy today well unemployment
is low and we're all delighted by that
this requires little you have is that
most of the new income in wealth
continues to go to the very very wealthy
right you'll have a situation now where
7 million more people lack health
insurance that used to have it and you
still have a situation where in states
all over this country it's hard for me
to believe this but it's true you got
people still working for 750 $8 an hour
because Trump and Republicans refused to
raise the minimum wage to a living wage
so to answer your question the economy
today is good thank God but you've got
tens of millions of workers still
struggling to put food on the table and
we've got to address their needs as part
of that let me ask just a quickly if
raise taxes on corporations which I know
you weren't happy with the tax cuts for
corporations aren't you afraid that that
is going to chill employment that those
companies are gonna say you know what we
have 100 employees we could do it with
50 nobody understands how that work
we're not gonna pay these higher taxes
we're not gonna you know you know we I
think we look at the world a little bit
differently but if you want to defend a
tax system in which Amazon owned by the
wealthiest person in this country a zero
in federal tax I don't think anybody
thinks that's that's fair good but I'm
saying it to raise taxes raise it from
zero across the country well we are
fewer people tax policy is complicated
and you got to do it right you didn't
hear me say we're gonna raise taxes on
small businesses yeah what we are
talking about is raising taxes on large
profitable corporations and on the
wealthiest people in this country and I
think that I discussed senator you look
at the list you're for the green new
deal and different policies within it
but you're for it generally we talked
about Medicare for all can we talk about
yeah we will free college tuition don't
you have an infrastructure plan we have
a shot of the current national debt
clock it stays Elba with a taking two
new trillion tonight and as we're
talking here it is ticking up
you've glial many of your plans but
there is a lot of doubt that your plans
might actually speed up that clock
dramatically so when you look at that do
you not care about that anymore I think
you're asking worth question of the
evening the president
threat in all due respect sir Trump gave
a trillion and a half dollar tax break
for the top 1% and large profitable
corporations and I find it so ironic
that my Republican colleagues in the
Senate local the high the debt they have
a word to say about that we've done many
stories not a criticism but what I am
saying is the masking year yep we in
fact I am concerned about the death
that's a legitimate concern every
American should be concerned about it
that's not something we should believe
into our kids and our grandchildren but
we pay for what we are proposing in
terms of Medicare for all we are paying
for that by eliminating as I said before
deductibles and premiums we're going to
save the average family money when we're
paying twice as much as other countries
we're gonna save money on health care I
talked about a tax on Wall Street
speculation that will help us make
colleges public colleges and
universities tuition-free we have a tax
plan to raise the trillion dollars we
need over a 10-year period to rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure so I think
you're talking to the one guy we pay for
what we are proposing unlike the
President of the United States perfect
[Applause]
is a therapist from South Whitehall
Township Amy what's your question hi I
work as a therapist specifically with
people struggling with opioid addiction
Pennsylvania is currently 4th in the
nation for opioid overdose deaths which
amounts to 15 people a day in
Pennsylvania as president what specific
policies would you implement in order to
address this crisis thank you thank you
for the work you're doing and let me say
it's not just Pennsylvania it's Vermont
it's new hampshire it is a terrible
terrible crisis for the first thing
first thing that I would do is make
certain that we never allowed Trump to
implement his plan which would throw
thirty-two million people off of the
health insurance that they have right
some of you remember and think about
what that would do to dealing with
opioids you may remember that during the
campaign you correct me if I'm wrong you
guys follow this stuff President Donald
Trump campaigned and he said I'm a
different type of Republican you
remember he said I'm not gonna cut
Medicaid I'm not gonna cut Medicare well
the last budget that he brought forth
called for a trillion and a half dollar
cut in Medicaid over a ten-year period
eight hundred and forty five billion
dollars in Medicare
what would a trillion and a half cut to
Medicaid do for our ability to combat
the opioid addiction so what we need in
fact is we need a series of ideas to
deal with this very very serious
addiction you know what the medic we are
facing a nation right now where our life
expectancy is actually going down and
one of the reasons is drug addiction it
is alcoholism it is suicide which the
doctors referred to as diseases of
despair when people are giving up on
life that's what happens so what we need
to do is to make sure that we have the
treatment capabilities which most states
don't have actually Vermont's doing
fairly well in that that means if you
all want to get off of that addiction
there is a place for you to go it's
difficult it's tough stuff but we have
to deal with addiction in a serious way
and invest in treatment for those who
are addicted for all of these plans
for all of these planets you say there
are enough taxes to raise to pay for all
of the plans yes there are bipartisan
independent groups who have looked at
those plans and say it just doesn't add
up what do you say to them we disagree
and sometimes these these plans done by
think tanks check out who funds the
think tanks simple right here is the
issue that we have to do but let me just
bring it down to a human level with the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world that's where we are right now do
you think we should be having the
highest rate of childhood poverty of
almost any major nation on earth we got
some moms here who are spending 15 20
thousand dollars a year trying to find
quality child care for their kids we
probably have a child care system which
is more dysfunctional than almost any
other country on Earth but we all know
that 0 to 4 are the most important years
you got hundreds of thousands of bright
young people in America today the
wealthiest country in the world they
can't afford to go to college and you've
got 40 million people struggling with
student debt you really think that we
cannot do better as a nation and on top
of that you got a handful of people who
own more wealth than the bottom half of
the American Society no I understand
that we're taking on corporate America
we're taking on the Republicans of
making on the Democratic establishment
taking on the drug companies taking on
the insurance companies take it on the
military industrial complex you know
what
I know that but I think what the
American people know president the
American people I think are ready to
deal with justice in America that's
that's what we're fighting for
and that's economic justice social
justice environmental justice racial
justice the President as you know has
said that the capacity for the asylum
seekers that were full at the border in
terms of housing and it's overflowing
it's a bad untenable situation right now
he has suggested has been very
controversial over the past few days
sending some of those people to
sanctuary cities which have said in the
past that they have open doors for
immigrants if they have open doors for
immigrants so where do the overflow that
we have no capacity for where do you
think they should go first or first
thought I mean this president let me
don't get into this friend I talk time
for that but what we have a problem at
the water series problem and what is the
problem the problem right now you
correct me if you think I'm wrong is
that we are now seeing desperate people
fleeing violence and misery and Honduras
El Salvador Guatemala with little
children walking a thousand miles
they're not trying to sneak in correct
me from what they're going up and they
say we want to silent because I don't
want my little girl to grow up to be
treated horribly by gangs okay now
you're right there are a whole lot of
people so what do we need to do we need
sensible immigration reform which
includes among other things getting
hundreds of new judges because the
system is now over Floyd who can deal
with these issues you're coming into the
country
are you really fleeing violence or is
another reason okay so you need to have
many many more judges to expedite the
process and new Asylum laws for me new
asylum that's what let's look but I you
know he
historically from an international and
national perspective and I speak as a
the son of an immigrant to himself not
in this kind of position but who came to
this country at the age of 17 from
Poland without a nickel in his pocket
internationally what the world has said
is that if you are fleeing violence if
your life is in danger that other
countries should welcome you in but we
need real comprehensive immigration
reform we don't need and let me say this
very clearly we don't need to demonize
immigrants facilities they need to go
somewhere because they're in that asylum
what about building where would you put
them what about building proper
facilities for them right now we're
right on the water
right on the border at the same people
live on the border should have more
facilities in their states but sanctuary
cities which have said they're also into
accepting people should not take now
this is a political act it's a political
decision so what you want to do let's
talk about immigration which is a
religion okay first of all instead of
demonizing immigrants maybe one say you
are but we have a president who
certainly does every single day what we
need is comprehensive immigration reform
that's what the American people want and
if we had a president who believed in
that we can actually do it what you also
want to do today one point you know
Trump ended the daca program that Obama
established you know what that means
that means every day more and more young
people who were raised in the United
States from two or three years of age
they're in the military they are
teachers they're working all over this
country they are now scared to death
that somebody's gonna pick them up and
throw them out of the country and that
is what Trump did we need to provide
legal status to those people and we need
and you name but Martha I'm not saying
this it's an easy issue but let's not
politicize it what we need as I said we
need the proper legal processes at the
water so that these issues can be
adjudicated to determine whether or not
people should be entitled to asylum and
you didn't talk about a wall or security
there but you've talked about that
before we need what a security of course
we do who argues with that doctors
without saying no I can't believe I
happen to believe that there are more
cost-effective ways to do that than
simply building let's go right Tony is a
real estate agent can complement
sylvania has our next question Tony
senator Sanders good luck in your
campaign thank you as a Syrian American
I want to be assured our country isn't
gonna partake in any foreign affairs
that don't directly affect our national
security I believe I believe we need to
stay out of Syria Venezuela and other
countries that have their own personal
issues do you wholeheartedly agree with
this sentiment or are you gonna become
another cog in the war machine
well Tony thank you that's an excellent
question you know we don't as a nation
we don't discuss far as quite as much as
we should uh Tony you're looking at a
guy once again not only voted against
the war in Iraq I helped lead the
opposition to the war in Iraq and if you
go back go back to YouTube and what I
said then is that wars have unintended
consequences rather is the tragedy of
Vietnam with so many people in my
generation are still suffering as a
result of that people sleeping out on
the streets and by the way we have got
to make sure that no veteran in this
country sleeps out in the street right
but let me get question let me just say
this this is in a sense good news and I
know you guys notice that in the last
month I led the effort along with
Senator Mike Lee was a conservative from
Utah Mike and I led the effort in the
Senate and some really great people in a
bipartisan way let it in the house and
what we've said is we think that the
United States should get out of the
saudi-led war in Yemen and and for the
first time since the War Powers Act was
passed 45 years ago we succeeded in the
house in the Senate let me say this in a
very serious way I'm being critical of
the president all night but let me just
say this the president has said that he
does not want to see this country
involved in endless wars and I agree
with that and mr. president tonight you
have the opportunity to do something
extraordinary sign that resolution Saudi
Arabia should not be determining the
military or foreign policy of this
country let's get out of Saudi Arabia
let's develop a bipartisan approach so
that we do not continue to be engaged in
you know wars like Afghanistan which is
what 18 years ago more so 19 so from a
foreign policy perspective which country
is the biggest threat to the u.s. I
don't know that I look I don't like
using the word threat because that says
oh my god we have to spend millions more
on the middle I'll give you an example
clearly you know we are concerned about
China and we're concerned about Russia
but here's the irony here you got people
who say we need to spend even more than
700 billion dollars a year more than the
next 10 nations combined on the military
you know why cuz I China is a real
potential enemy these are the same
people who are investing billions of
dollars building the Chinese economy I
find that somewhat ironic all right so
I don't like to use the word enemy
clearly we need a strong defense we need
to bring the United States and the rest
of the world together do everything we
can to rid this world of nuclear weapons
and I'll tell you what else in my view
is a national security issue and that is
we have God as a nation to reject
Trump's idea that climate change is a
hopes
and you know I'm sure you're familiar
with the scientific reports that tell us
that we have all of 12 years to
significantly cut carbon emissions or
else they will be irreparable damage to
the United States and countries all over
the world so we have a moral
responsibility in my view to transform
our energy system and leave this planet
healthy and habitable for our children
and our grandchildren and by the way
when we do that we create millions of
good things let me ask you waiting
because you brought up a question of
omission just one quick to Fremont
emissions but you think we should
eliminate nuclear power which I know
they did in Vermont but it ended up
actually moving your emissions higher by
16% in Vermont because nuclear doesn't
have any coefficient honestly I don't
think that that's correct I think we are
moving well I can tell you that my city
nuclear in my city in Burlington Vermont
which is the largest city in the state
of Vermont I believe that all of our
energy is now renewable that's something
I started back way back when I when I
was available and all the cities are
doing the same but Marty here is the
point here is the point yeah I happen to
believe yeah I do believe we should
phase-out not eliminate it tomorrow we
should face out nuclear power plants but
here is the main point the main point is
that if we do not combat climate change
I I fear very much the kind of world
that we're leaving to our kids in terms
of more droughts more flooding more
extreme weather disturbances war rising
ocean levels and when those things
happen by the way they become a national
security issue because people migrate if
I can't you know if I'm living in the
Mideast someplace and I can't grow food
on my land I'm gonna pick up and leave
and that causes conflicts you know you
said senator that you wanted a strong
defense but your plan does call for
significant constant defense would that
would that send a message to the rest of
the world that we are weaker no no no no
no we are now spending bread we're
spending you know more than the next ten
nations combined including many of our
allies we're now spending over
100 billion dollars a year on defense so
we need a strong defense but I will also
tell you this we have a Pentagon and
there are some Republicans Mike ends
come the ranking member of the Budget
Committee Mike is the chairman of it and
Mike I think and I are in agreement on
this is a conservative Republican that
there's something wrong when the
Pentagon
is the only major agency of government
that has not undertaken or completed a
major audit and there are very few
people who doubt that there's a massive
amount of waste and overruns
you remember John McCain late John
McCain we talked about the incredible
cost overruns with it with the existing
in the Pentagon so ion we do need a
strong defense and I support a strong
defense but I don't support you know
waste and profiteering within the
military so we're gonna do try to do
about 15 seconds all right first one is
a very serious question you said
yesterday I watched her rally in
Pittsburgh that no one should tell a
woman what to do with her own body
controversial with regard to abortion do
you believe that a woman should be able
to terminate a pregnancy up until the
moment of birth look I think that that
happens very very rarely and I think
this is being made into a political
issue
okay so I think it's rare it's being
made into a political issue but at the
end of the day I believe that the
decision over abortion belongs to a
woman and a physician not the federal
government not the state government
perfect you are looking to become the
first Jewish president you're also a
staunch supporter of congresswoman Ilhan
Omar I just taught the Ilhan about twice
in my life so
but you've tried to expect we need
support for this is what I do support I
support a a Muslim member of Congress
not to be attacked every single day in
outrageous races sure my question is
that even if some fellow Democrats had
some problems have accused of you her of
using language kind of associated with
anti-semitism can you understand why
some Jewish Americans would have a
problem with some of them yeah I can
understand I think that that is not
quite right and I think that Alana has
got to do maybe a better job in speaking
to the Jewish community but if you if
your question to me as though I think
she is anti-semitic no I don't know it's
not her I'm saying in the thread but
here is the point also not gonna trip
him on Jewish I lost my father's family
was devastated by Hitler so this is an
issue of some sensitivity to me
so I will do everything in my power and
I hope that every member of Congress
will fight not only anti-semitism but
racism and anti-muslim activity so that
we create a non-discriminatory society
but it is not anti-semitic to be
critical of a right-wing government in
Israel that's right
to believe that murderers and rapists or
thieves or child molesters should have
the right to vote from prison
all right this is in my state it I
recently researched this it turns out
they made our Constitution in the state
of Vermont for hundreds of years
everybody has the right to vote okay so
I think you make VistaVision if somebody
does something terrible they're a rapist
or a murderer we send them away
sometimes we send them away from life
but I also think that integral to who we
are as Americans no matter what kind of
terrible things you did you're paying
the price maybe you're in jail for the
rest of your life but you have the right
to vote all right and I'll tell you why
once one of the things one of the things
that upsets me very much is we have
cowardly Republican governors who are
working overtime to suppress the vote to
make it harder for people of color for
poor people for young people to vote so
once you start it's like you committed a
crime you can't vote or you did this you
can't vote you did that you can't vote I
don't like that every American 18 of age
of older who's a citizen in this country
has the right to vote
[Music]
ridiculous
and you have done a scientific study
saying that everybody wants to you know
encourage voters one of the one of the
great problems
one of the political product dumb quests
that we're facing right now is the
effort to deny people the right to vote
and look I've run for office many times
in Vermont sometimes I've lost sometimes
I've won but I don't stay up nights
trying to figure out how I can PP keep
people from voting cuz they might put a
guy to more quick things we've been told
that the redacted Muller report the
redacted version of the motor report is
coming out Thursday
you don't talk a lot about the Special
Counsel investigation on the campaign
trail why not a campaign issue well
because everybody else is talking about
it look it is what it is it's coming out
I think to the extent that it as much of
it as can be made publicly yogi should
be made public I think the American
people have a right to know what's in
the report period you think the Joe
Biden is a progressive look like this
guy so is somebody who I have known for
many many years Joe is a friend of mine
and by the way I hope very much yeah I
don't take it the Democratic primary we
got a lot of good people many of them
personal friends of mine that we have a
debate about the issues and not about
personality so Joe is a friend about
[Applause]
you're trying to do that go as a friend
he will give his point of view
I give mind let the people decide of the
20 potential Democratic candidates you
have one that you think will be the
toughest challenger to you I have no
idea today there was a poll that had us
in the lead tomorrow will be an
eighteenth place who knows what goes on
it is the best that we at all I could
tell you what I am proud of is it now
campaign media paid attention the money
we raise good more important to me we
have over 1 million people who have
signed up to volunteer give you the
floor here for a closing statement
oh thank you
we're gonna give them a floor for a
closing statement here all right well
thank you very much
and I hope I wasn't too hot that's all
right all right all right look thank you
all very much for being here and thank
everybody for watching just a couple of
points I think sometimes the divisions
in this country get a little bit too hot
okay at the end of the day we are all
Americans who love this country and I
also think and the media place is not a
good role in this again not just Fox is
we have a lot more in common than most
people think we do all right poll after
poll should we raise the minimum wage to
a living wage yes should we rebuild our
crumbling infrastructure should we make
sure that our veterans get the health
care that they have earned all right
should we make sure that we do not cut
Social Security or Medicare or Medicaid
should we give huge tax breaks to
billionaires you know that's how most
people feel so I hope I hope look I'm
looking forward to a good campaign and
the last point that I want to make and I
thank [ __ ] up you know for the
opportunity of being here and and that
is I want to see our country have the
highest voter turnout in the
industrialized world not one of the
lowest right no matter what you abuse
all get involved in the political
process stand up and fight to make this
a better country thank you all very much
absolutely fantastic
vania had some great questions I'll be
back tomorrow 6 p.m. for special report
from Washington listen I watched this
crap all the time and this was one of
the best townhall performances that I
can remember by a Republican or a
Democrat I have copious notes and we are
going to be going over it in detail
today and tomorrow on the program if
you've just been watching the stream
please hit the subscribe button
subscribe to our Channel
we are not that far from a million
subscribers and I would appreciate you
hitting that subscribe button to
everybody who has been saying you want
to call in and tell me how stupid I am
and how bad Bernie is well you might get
the opportunity very shortly if you want
to have me open the phone lines sign up
at WWE
I once Evan eight-30 4750 and then we'll
hear from a lot of you fine people
including people who want it quote
destroy me
I'm ready Maggie Gallagher has signed up
this evening
Matthew Gillett org EA has signed up
Joanne Ramsey has signed up meaning that
we have three new members already also a
few YouTube memberships will be which we
will count towards that including Steven
fort no that that was actually a
different day who has signed up today
including let me get the names correct
here v is new member number four of the
evening and Carson K is new member
number five of the evening and - Requiem
- is new member number six so if six
more people sign up I will open up the
phone lines at 607 eight-30 47 50 an
extraordinary a truly extraordinary
performance Brian Stevens becoming new
member number seven by the way remember
YouTube takes 30% our website only takes
2.9 percent to process your payments
okay so we hit a lot more of the money
if you sign up at wwe.com I will open up
the phone lines if folks sign up ty
McDonald is new member number eight let
me go through some of these super chats
because they were coming in Fast and
Furious and then we will get to the
phone lines if indeed it becomes time to
do it
let's
here in before Bernie's criticized for
being a shill for medical research
grants okay yeah that that's not
happening Kaela Empson says do you find
that Bernie struggles to communicate I
find that aoc communicates a lot of
these same topics more effectively Kaela
no I don't think so
I don't I don't think so at all Jeremy
Sutton with a 1999 British Pound super
shot why don't you ask countries who do
this successfully like Canada UK France
and Germany
oh yeah Trump has burned those bridges
absolutely
political psycho thank you so much for
live-streaming the townhall keep up the
good work David thank you
and her name romantic Mary reject Becky
G Leslie G or not C Natasha you know
naughty Natasha is a vegetarian and I'm
not so that would be difficult for
marriage so I think I might reject her
marry Becky G and have a have a romantic
evening with with Leslie G I don't
actually know who Leslie G is Howard
Roark with a 99-cent super chat F a b-1
says it's dangerous to go alone here
take this five euro appreciate that
Steve B so when Bernie brings the jobs
back from overseas what will he do when
automation eliminates them yang 2020
I've been critical of elected officials
or want to be elected officials who
don't simply say some of these jobs
aren't coming back I understand why
because if they do it their opponent
says look what a defeatist they're
saying the jobs aren't coming back but
it's the reality and I do appreciate
that Andrew yang is being upfront about
that
Jeremy Sutton what WTF is a socialist
college traitor are you in China I
didn't think you hung political
dissidents in the free USA what happened
to unalienable rights guaranteed by your
Constitution I don't know what you're
talking about
Chrissy wins says keep up the great work
David and the team love the show thank
you nuni sends a 99 cent super chat
Jeremy Sutton stop describing the crisis
and get to a solution you should have
prepared for this reference Portugal oh
this is during the health insurance or
opioid thing okay real life Jolie says
I'm not sure whether or not I'm audible
with maitake box on the
phone so could you say whether you heard
me on my voicemail a few months ago you
know we get a hundred voicemails a day
so I unfortunately don't remember that
big talk little talk says Bernie tulsi
20/20 Wow
let's hope not Irene Humphries says go
Bernie Joseph Lawrence thank you for
sharing the paid news now
Omaha cop block with a dollar super chat
incredible TV unless Fox has a doctored
tape of Bernie saying the N word he
absolutely crushed it can you start a
segment on the show called the weekly
cringe where you cover cringe and
politics love the show so I'm going to
think about Jer oh I lost Jeremy
Sutton's latest one there it is what
about what you're about to be paying on
interest to service your budget deficit
keep the Republicans in office and that
will soon surpass defense spending okay
Brandon the fish is a new member voor de
Voort is a new member
StuH never says Bernie owned that like a
boss brass balls to go on Fox News
thanks thanks so much for having this on
he's amazing and so are you I'm a member
one of the best Town Hall performances
I've seen truly Griffin sweat is a new
member
Alex Malone says sorry I call every week
but please Google yang news Ombudsman
mr. ft media with a british pound super
chat Lukas Warren or big fan of your
show up and listening for a few years
this is my first Super chat expect more
in the future and sign up now Thank You
Carly Mayfield says you're awesome and
I've got a bunch of new members to think
the phone lines might get opened listen
we we mostly are funded not by huge
corporations but just by normal folks
who say I like what David's doing I'm
gonna sign up on his website join
pakman.com coupon codes are available
and some really awesome people signed up
tonight Jenny Ward is a new member
Damien Scott is a new member Amy bori is
a new member
Peter Conover has signed up Dillon our
tune ian is a new member
Coleco Castille has signed up
Rodrigo Arriola is a new member
Kenny
today I hope I didn't say that that
wrong Kenny Hughes is a new member
Roy fishel Michelle is a new member and
Denise Bay hem has signed up on patreon
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
already welcomed Maggie Gallagher and
everybody before so listen I'm a man of
my word and it's time to open up the
phone line 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the
number feel free to call in I am going
to get my note-taking supplies we make
very very detailed notes about everybody
who calls in so we know should they be
blocked should I give them priority when
they call in
are they good callers are they bad
callers but I will be opening the phone
lines right now at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
this program is supported by great
people who sign up or who send super
chats a new sign up from Shamari Vasquez
thank you so much Shamari really really
appreciate your support you can start
calling in at 6 1 7 8 3 zero
4750 and i will go to the phone lines
momentarily Aaron Holloway is also a new
contributor $5 a month on patreon thank
you so much for signing up and a couple
of other super chats here what are your
thoughts on yang and white nationalists
it scares me already asked them about it
personally last week on the show check
it out on our YouTube archive the
political one will you debate Kyle on
the Moller report over 9000 I put out a
video today which points out that I
think basically my almost my entire
audience isn't actually in agreement
with other leftists about the Moller
Russia stuff I think that we need to be
in flame rather than in flame there
Mariah Stiles Brown has signed up and
memberships are rolling in listen just
to kick it off let's go to Jimmy from
Philly I didn't go to him last time
we're gonna go to him in a second
actually Jimmy I'm sorry I need you to
just hold on one moment here
don't hang up Jimmy I'm going to get
everything connected and set up here and
then I will talk to Jimmy from Philly
mean
while Lukas Warner is a new member
Karoline Coopersmith has signed up
really appreciate the support this is a
program that depends on the support of
the great people that are signing up and
it lets us do live streams and take
phone calls and all sorts of stuff so
let's go to the phones Jimmy from Philly
what do you got for me today buddy
congratulations David you shall obey me
on YouTube how's it feel I have no idea
what you're talking about
explain to me what you're talking about
I'm shadow band I can't I can't type it
in the chat I can't super chat no one
responds to me anymore and due to that
Jimmy listen I'm you you you I want to
be really really honest with you here
which is always what I do I don't have
the time to go ban people on YouTube we
get too many fighters Aidid I don't know
what you said I don't know what
transpired during the livestream but
Jimmy I don't know what you're talking
about and I don't even I didn't even
think that shadow bands were a thing on
YouTube I thought you were either just
blocked or not blocked you know more
than I do Jimmy yeah I can type a
message but no one else can see it
okay well you got on the phone do you
have anything you usually call in and
talk about your YouTube comments do you
actually have a political comment today
well my thing with Bernie Sanders is yes
he supported his shooter
how can anyone respect this man the fact
that even shows his face is amazing
sorry he did what now he supported his
cheater natl people about Ellery screwed
he's and everything's to be and she's
gonna be fair to him now these political
people could screw them once you don't
think they're gonna screw them again
so you don't think the DNC is gonna
manage the primary fairly is that right
Jimmy absolutely they didn't before what
leads me to believe they will know Jimmy
Davis it's 7:40 6 p.m. on April 15 2019
and for the first time in our storied
history of you calling into the show
you've made a salient and pithy
political point I want to go mad let me
make another one David here's how 2020
is going to go the progressives are
gonna win Donald Trump you
action because they're going to split
the Democrats then what's going to
happen is the progressives are going to
start their own party mark my words
all right well Jimmy uh Jimmy from
Philly uh angry landscaper Jimmy from
Philly making a political picture
Jimmy how many beers have you had
tonight no none yeah you sound lucid in
a weird way so I appreciate that
I'm always lucid David all right Jimmy
we'll talk to you later
okay let's see I have a so here's why
the system is so good I have danielle
marked as a very good caller and to go
to Danielle so Danielle you're next up
today what's going on oh my god hello
I'm so honored that you consider me to
be a very good caller last time it may
have been and they have been yeah well I
suppose why I just always calling
because I love to hear your voice and I
love hearing you talk I just can't help
with the call-in and I suppose my only
criticism is that Jimmy talks too much
she gives in too much airtime I
understand the need for such a character
but I think that perhaps I don't know
maybe not every live show yeah and
that's what I know Daniel I don't know
if you missed the last couple of live
live shows but we have not gone to Jimmy
from Philly because it was getting to be
too too much and I went to the chat the
live chat said do not go to Jimmy from
Philly so I didn't and I've also he's
left me one two three four five
voicemails since last week and we've
played none of them so we're dialing
down Jimmy from Philly a little bit and
I suppose I have one last question and
that is will you ever do like a
meet-and-greet or do you or Kyle
kolinsky are interested in like doing
the meet-and-greet because I would love
to hug you guys and realize yeah we so
right now we are in discussions to
organize a an in-person david pakman
show event in Boston although since
we've not done it before it's most
likely going to be limited to like 50
people so it'll be relatively small just
to sort of like a proof of concept but
we may do more in the future if it goes
well oh that makes sense but I'd be
afraid to go to Boston because I'm black
but nonetheless I hope I would be able
to see you one day you would be fine you
would be fine we would
for your safety Danielle but I I
appreciate the sentiment great to hear
from you okay take care okay let's go to
a let me just mention a couple of super
chats here because there are more super
chats coming in Vinny 3c sends a dollar
cult of Malgus says can you post the
number in the chat
can someone type it in at six one seven
eight three zero 4750 Ismael Aguilar
says love the show gracias David thank
you and greg cannom own says keep up the
good work became a member last month
what do you think about Trump busing
migrants across the country I say bring
them in I don't know what you mean by
bring them in like arrest them or
mussing them bussing them out of the
country do you mean I need a little more
info on that let's go to our next caller
from the five seven zero area code who's
calling today from five seven zero hey
it's Nick from Pennsylvania can you hear
me yeah what's going on Nick question
well first I'll tell you the question
then I'll explain a little bit why was
this wondering what your thoughts were
on banning animal agriculture or phasing
it out over you know so many years a
reason being was yeah I hear a lot of
talk about people talking about the US
and the lifespan you know not getting
better so they talk about a lot about
drugs and everything but the leading
cause of death is heart disease and the
only diet proved in the reverse heart
disease is by dr. Caldwell Esselstyn at
the Cleveland Clinic and so if you have
the you know plant-based nutrition you
know it's proven to reverse the leading
cause of death and then you have the
emissions from the animal agriculture
you know from all the wastes and you
know then you have like poor living
conditions for the animals and you know
so if you have the health aspect of it
you know there's no diets or there's no
scientific you know proven disease that
you absolutely need and require an
protein or animal products in general so
curiously your side so she's done kind
of research I have there's a lot of
stuff in there that I just don't think
matches up with the science I'd
encourage you to go to school or
scholar.google.com and look up some of
this stuff so number one there are so if
you so so carnitine for example is an
amino acid that you can only get from
from animal products
there's the b12 question of course you
can take a supplement if you're not
consuming any animal products but as far
as the the health benefits
I believe in reducing consumption for
both environmental and health reasons of
meats with high saturated fat as far as
cholesterol goes the overwhelming
science right now indicates that eating
cholesterol does not raise cholesterol
in blood saturated fat certainly seems
to be a contributing factor but there's
more and more peer-reviewed cyanide
again well done like I I didn't
interrupt you let me speak uninterrupted
if you may it does appear that
cholesterol production by the body may
even be related to carbohydrate
consumption particularly carbohydrates
that have a high glycemic load white
carbs empty carbs as they are called so
I think that we're probably not on the
same page in terms of the science so
we'd need to kind of agree on that
before we can really talk about
conclusions okay well I just like to
mention quick the Academy of Nutrition
and Dietetics one of the largest
authorities on nutrition says that well
plan vegan diets are suitable for all
stages of life you have to understand
when I talk about studies you've got to
do double-blind studies that are not
observational based on the past you you
need the the one way that we can
actually study this stuff in science the
recommendations that different groups
have given at different times have very
often been proven to be the wrong
recommendations so there's one way that
we can study this stuff and it is with
when it comes to blinding the the tests
they need to be blinded and we we have
comparison groups control groups that's
the way that we study this
not just saying X group recommends Y or
Z that's not really peer-reviewed
science right I understand well there
was a period like I said the you know
dr. Caldwell Esselstyn research was
peer-reviewed and clinically proven the
reverse heart disease so what when
you're talking about dietary cholesterol
not impacting you know blood cholesterol
levels the reason that is is when they
they manipulate the study design because
they take people with already naturally
high or high cholesterol who are eating
the standard American diet you know they
might have cholesterol where they
consider good which is on their you know
maybe like 185 or on you know under that
200 mark we're suggesting is a
conspiracy to make every cholesterol
related study effectively a sham study
and there's absolutely no evidence that
that's the case and I would be glad to
provide counter evidence at another
point because I think we've probably
spent enough time on it but I do
appreciate the phone call thank you very
very much okay let's go to our next
caller from the nine seven eight area
code who's calling in today from the
nine seven eight area code
hi David my name is Tiffany Stas hey
Tiffany what's going on I just wanted to
mention a few things I was actually on
you did a segment on the Vatican awhile
back and I was part of that on your show
so that was a great video thank you
also I know that the you know people are
giving you flak for no stupid reasons on
your chat so I just wanted to kind of
boost you up instead of knock you down
well thank you you are intelligence and
even though I am a lesbian you are an
attractive guy and you should not deal
with any of that crap which I don't
think you do anyways Wow
additionally additionally I want to
thank you for supporting trans people I
know people like Jimmy who's a complete
ignorant [ __ ] I'm pretty sure I can say
that on your show Oh sir is doesn't know
any anything about trans people he's not
subtle about it so I just wanted to
thank you for sticking up for trans
people
because you know I'm trans so all right
well I will stick up for everybody that
deserves to have someone sticking up for
them Tiffany really appreciate your
phone call my pleasure
all right take care a couple super chats
to look at Zack Forbes Restivo says Zack
from Pittsburgh here David which
candidate do you think would best
support LGBT plus slash minority rights
I think most of the candidates have a
very very long track record of LGBT plus
minority right support I guess on LGBT
tulsi gabbard more recently changed her
opinion but for the most part I think
all of the candidates on the Democratic
side on those issues are quite strong
and her name says you should start a
political twitch like destiny and Hasan
[ __ ] debate tons of more on
conservatives yeah two people I'm in
touch with destiny and Hasan maybe I
just feel like I've built so much
support here on YouTube six hundred and
twenty something thousand subscribers
that why start from scratch on Twitch
and have to build an audience when we've
got a great audience here I'm worried
about sort of spreading myself a little
too thin stun ever says beans in avocado
have l-carnitine just saying I did if
that's true I didn't know that I spoke
to a doctor over the weekend actually
about this gee burns I'm so glad you
streamed this 2v1 debate not really a
town hall I much preferred your analysis
to the corporate drivel I would have
endured watching Fox News thank you for
your great content thank you for the
support
Ranger Jenny cowspiracy dot org I'm a
Bernie fan but love Yang and Williamson
- what are your thoughts on her total
woowoo
pseudoscience nonsense not not
interested not even worthy of discussion
in my view so shocked by the truth bombs
she dropped on CNN yeah she says some
things that make sense that lots of
people say but not for me Jeremy Sutton
my comment about China referred to
hateful violent chats one mentioned
hanging socialist college traders
nothing to do with your commentary all
right Lucas Warner thank you David
viewers since 2016 signed up today
appreciate it and ft asks do we have
time to reverse abrupt climate change
every day
it is more of a question what of climate
change can actually be reversed and
sadly it's unclear whether all of it can
which is why it is so important that we
get moving on that issue
much more quickly than we are under this
administration let's go to our caller
from the 469 area code who's calling
today from 469 hello yeah that's you
who's this um yeah I'm Sean I was in
Dallas um I was calling because I wanted
to know what your spots were on Andrew
yang specifically around social issues
where it seems to be like he doesn't at
least in my from my perspective but he
doesn't really have any strong as I put
this he doesn't really speak about it
when he's debating and if he does talk
about it he just only speaks about it
from like the ubi as a solution kind of
perspective so I want to be thought
about that specifically on LGBTQ rights
we're on his website he has kind of like
one sentence that's kind of vague in my
opinion as someone who is LGBTQ when
there are so many other candidates that
are you know I just kind of expect more
from him I guess what I'm trying to say
but I wanted to do yeah I mean it's
interesting what you're bringing up you
know I've said for a while that I think
foreign policy is Bernie Sanders his
weakest area and in fact in my notes to
discuss tomorrow on the show I made a
note that the weakest point was when he
was asked about who he sees as the
biggest geopolitical threat along the
same lines I think social issues are
Andrew Yang's weakest so I basically
agree with you I have no reason to think
that he has the wrong views on social
issues I just think he's not addressing
them nearly enough and I completely
agree I thought that too but then here's
something I was really more problematic
for me is that like I noticed he isn't
really engaged in the conversation on
Twitter about it at all like I literally
went on Twitter and just starts Andrew
yang LGBTQ or you know just to kind of
see like Oh is there a history of him
supporting it yeah and it didn't really
exist and that was kind of like really
bizarre to me at least and then not only
that but also about like racial issues
it's kind of like there really wasn't
three of em by I said unless it's
through the perspective of you know my
ubi plan as a solution to everything is
correct like it didn't really feel like
there was really a history there and so
I kind of I used to support him
to be honest I've kind of told that back
I'm still like Barney is my number one
but I was kind of thinking he could have
been number two but then it just started
to feel kind of weird there for me and
then but yeah that's kind of a whole
thing but also on the issue of kind of
torts a Town Hall I guess do you think
they everyone all the mainstream media
outlets continue to assume that button
is gonna run for president I just kind
of just kind of be running assumption
right is that buttons gonna jump that
they see you although I don't I don't
know I mean I'm just taking a
wait-and-see approach I don't know why a
lot of corporate media seems so
convinced right but it's almost like
you're pushing it but anyway um they I
think do you think he will jump in or do
you think because it's kind of getting
late now really I mean you've had people
but the Budaj you know does it yesterday
do his event and then it's kind of see
like the money is beginning to dry out
there's a lot of establishment
candidates that are second up almost all
the money so do you really think that
he's gonna jump in I have no idea this
is why I'm just saying I don't know I
mean in the latest so tomorrow on the
show an emerson poll that was released
yesterday has Bernie ahead of Biden now
which has not been the case in any
national poll that I'm aware of up until
this point in time so it's possible that
the reason it's taking a while is that
the numbers keep getting worse and worse
for Biden I really have no idea I have
no idea whatsoever but I think if he's
going to he's got to do it within the
next month right yeah I took I
definitely agree like it just seems it's
just bizarre cuz every all that I mean
I'm talking MSNBC though likes Fox even
tonight we're just kind of like finds
gonna jump in and it's like I don't know
but yeah I'm glad I got to talk to you
all right thank you for the phone call
well great to hear from you appreciate
it
couple other super chats to mention VIN
III see is back in with another dollar
super chat Harry pothead says EFT which
I'll become a member Friday all right
and be person says hey David I'm 18 and
you have been an amazing role model
really appreciate
that it's been a nearly two-hour stream
and I've got a run but I appreciate
everybody who joined me and I will do
another stream later this week